x.x I'm hitting X skip the story xx xx
through that's not a game it's a movie
what there was it look like that it
looks so fake it look better in 93 it's
10 Spielberg must be rolling over in his
grave he's not hmm
nevermind I'm drew Coolidge and I'm here
to help answer the question why does the
CG in Jurassic world look worse than
Jurassic Park hide your lawyers in the
nearest bathroom stall hold onto your
books
it's hashtag news when the first trailer
for Jurassic world was released many
commented about the shoddy quality of
the CG it's possible that part of the
problem is that many times filmmakers
have to use an earlier rendering of the
scene in order to get a trailer out in
time but they update the graphics before
the movie actually comes out so the CG
that we see in the trailer looks a
little off you can see this scene change
over the course the various trailers and
should look better in the finalized
movie as even more proof
check out this early version of Star
Lords mask from an early guardians of
the galaxy trailer compared to the final
movie but why does the older movie look
better let's take a trip back to that
distant bygone era called the 90s the
decade that brought you Point Break
fallout the x-files and a Clinton
gearing up for the White House so
different from where we are now back in
those days a little movie called
Jurassic Park was released now Jurassic
Park was a sensational mega hit for many
reasons but chief among them was its
impressive
highly advanced use of effects and I
don't just mean Jeff Goldblum's Chester
mm-hmm look at that I guess so why did
the CG effects work so well in the
original Jurassic Park but not Jurassic
world well for one thing in Jurassic
Park CG was used as a last resort there
are only actually 14 minutes of dinosaur
visual effects in the original just 14
minutes of dinosaurs and only four of
those four minutes made on a computer
those were the scenes with velociraptors
Brachiosaurus is and
now the rest were a dazzling mix of
animatronics puppetry miniatures and
stop-motion animation
otherwise known as practical effects
things that the actors can actually
reach out and touch in real life that is
one big pile of [ __ ] they literally made
a full-size 9000 pound animatronic t-rex
now compare that to this
computer-generated scene from Jurassic
world you see a stadium of composited
people watching a composited dinosaur
eat a composited fish it's hard for it
to not look like black fish the animated
series CGI was less commonly used back
then because it used to take a lot
longer famous Jeep chase scene in
Jurassic Park actually took 12 hours to
render each frame of the entire sequence
and just to give you an idea of that
this shot of the t-rex breaking through
the log is 75 frames long that's a lot
of dinners with Grandma which is how I
measure time nowadays that can be
accomplished much faster and is to keep
up with all the movies that require
extensive CG and while the technology
was used very consciously in the
original modern movies use CGI like it's
going out of style movies are now full
of moments that defy the laws of physics
like this scene from Lord of the Rings
why do our brains have issues with these
images it's because of our understanding
of physics we get that when something
heavy Falls it affects our real-world in
a certain way so in san andreas for
example when this big thing hits the
ground we feel it in a way that we
understand but in fantasy movie
sequences created entirely with CGI
we have no reference point which means
it subconsciously disconnects our brains
for being able to feel and relate to the
visuals I mean I don't know what a tiny
elf man sliding on an elephant trunk
should look or feel like ok I do but
most people don't here's another way to
think about it imagine seeing a
character cut their finger on a sharp
pair of scissors you can picture it and
it even makes you kind of cringe to
think about it but now imagine cutting
your finger on a photon laser beam or
magic it's harder to imagine and you
don't really feel that uneasiness
anymore as a result that's the
disconnect I'm not saying we can't have
these fantastical elements in our films
but directors need to remember that as
you add more and more of these
disconnects you have less to cling on to
now you're just watching an expensive
cartoon and while effects don't make a
good movie making you feel like someone
is in real danger in a way that you can
actually believe and connect with makes
you care about them putting characters
in a world of liquid jelly doesn't
resonate although it does sound
delicious
luckily action movies have always had
great acting and amazing dialogue to
make up for it I don't control the
Raptors it's a relationship it's based
on mutual respect another thing that
makes a lot of modern movies look
ridiculous is the rampant use of color
grading which is when colors on a film
are altered to give it a more specific
look this became popular with the Coen
Brothers movie o brother where art thou
which was color graded to make the whole
movie look like an old sepia tinged
photo that you might see in your
grandma's house herb her Instagram
filmmakers notice that the colors on
opposite sides of the color wheel look
good together since most people in
movies are white sorry and orange is the
closest color to that skin tone most
modern movies tend to emphasize the
oranges and the teals which is the color
on the opposite side and they end up
making everything look like some fantasy
video game land color grading didn't
really exist when the original Jurassic
Park movie was made so the entire
effects team had to instead make the
movie look like the real world I know
it's crazy idea now finally movies today
seem to forget that big effects moments
should give the viewer sense of awe you
should see it you should
say how did they do that now when you
see a completely CGI image you just
think I guess they use computers or
something we still have hope however
well it's not animatronics director
Colin Trevorrow claims to have used
motion capture with actual people for
most of the dinosaurs like Chris Pratt's
velociraptor game because nothing says
natural dinosaur movements like a bunch
of humans and bodysuits hit subscribe
for more answers to the questions you
really want to know about it like if you
really wish I was more orange and teal
and go ahead and comment if you think
I'm actually made out of ones and zeros
because a person this odd-looking can't
really exist I'm drew and I want you to
play that remix of Jeff Goldblum's
laughs at my funeral
that's my amazing grace
and